dans le 13h de france 2 alors là je
pense que ça va vous faire réagir parce
que c'est assez choquant tout de même on
a découvert le témoignage de claire
marie claire marie c'est un médecin
généraliste qui a été agressée sur son
lieu de travail à regarder claire marie
est encore sous le choc de l'agression
qu'elle a subie un an pour surmonter son
traumatisme
elle a décidé de poursuivre son patient
justice le jour de l'agression elle
assurer un remplacement dans ce quartier
tranquille du centre ville jusqu'à
tomber sur un patient contrarié de ne
pas avoir à faire à son médecin traitant
peu les st louis ne m'a pas regardée et
ne m'a pas répondu
je le salue une deuxième fois en lui
demandant ce qui l'amenait fait il a
attendu que je m'assieds pour me dire
que j'avais des questions stupides et
puis là il continue en disant mais je ne
vous aime pas et puis arrêtez d'être
plus bête que vous ne l'êtes déjà dit
écoutez je suis pas là pour me faire
insulter donc on arrête la cua et
essayer en ouvrant la porte qu'à son
passage il
mais un bon visage jamais on s'imagine
que quelqu'un va vous porter un coup
alors c'est assez choquant par koné moi
parce que c'est vrai qu'ils sont les
médecins sont là pour nous aider en
retour ils reçoivent ce type d'agression
mail 35 agressions de médecins
enregistré en 2010 est pas un record et
la majorité des agressions concernent
les femmes médecins jimmy une réflexion
sur ce que l'on vienne voilà c'est vrai
que c'est accablant parce
qu'effectivement le médecin souvent il
subit un peu tout ce qui se passe et les
conséquences des frustrations des
patients en salles d'attentes blindé un
délai de consultation par acceptable une
douleur une ordonnance qui va pas comme
il faut au moment où il faut mais malgré
tout on n'est pas là pour eux n'est pas
des plus chics gaulle et se dire qu'il
ya eu mille finalement je pense qu'en
réalité ces chiffres sont sous-estimés
les siens récemment j'ai les consoeurs
qui fait des visites à domicile qui a
été agressé par un patient avec des
insultes racistes
c'est une femme bien évidemment et elle
a reçu donc des coûts elle n'a pas porté
plainte car les raisons seule elle se
sent elle s'est sortie dépassé presque
elle se demande si elle n'est pas
coupable
si finalement le patient ne va pas avoir
des problèmes car j'aimerais rappeler
aux gens que c'est une circonstance
aggravante attaqué un soignant je
rappelle que frapper un médecin c'est
donc comme vous le dites si tu as une
circonstance aggravante si le médecin à
moins de 8 jours d'itt été l'agresseur
en cours tout de même trois ans de
prison et 45000 euros damende si le
médecin à plus de 8 jours d'itt été
l'agresseur encourt cinq ans de prison
et 75000 euros d'amendé il faut rappeler
quand même c'est simple fait est ce qui
est assez dingue c'est que ça se passe
vraiment en principalement en ville et
dans les centres villes ça représente
plus de la moitié des agressions qui
sont dans les centres villes
très peu en banlieue notamment et le
truc c'est que y'a que 38 % des médecins
qui vraiment vos goûts et porte plainte
donc il faut vraiment qu'ils libèrent
leur parle parce qu'effectivement c'est
pas de leur fait c'est pas normal et le
problème de se dire est ce que parce
qu'on aura des problèmes ou pas ben en
fait au final on s'en moque un petit peu
c'est oui mais voilà ils sont jusqu'au
bout médecin saison passée c'est un bon
deal gut s'est finalement bien ça va lui
nuire il faudrait peut-être passer à
autre chose au renom il faut aller au
bout des plaintes qu'elle quelle soit on
avait le don de faire tabasser une
insulte suffit largement à déposer
plainte
on peut rien laisser passer bien
suracheté accès qu des haltes et dites
nous ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
en avez déjà observée est ce que vous
avez des médecins dans votre entourage
qui vous ont raconté des de tels
témoignages et et que pensez vous de ces
agressions qui se dit généraliste même
parce que la frustration se déverse sur
le premier convoi évidemment c'est le
médecin